يعني حتى نسمع نداءات من الاهالي من
الناشطين من الاعلاميين من يعني الجهات
المعنيه بانقاذ هؤلاء بان الوقت بدا ينفذ
امام المئات من العائلات وقد تتضاءل
امامهم فرص البقاء على قيد الحياه لان
الامكانيات خاصه في مناطق شمال غرب سوريا
امكانيات بسيطه وتكاد تكون يعني غير يعني
غير مناسبه لمثل للتعامل مع مثل هذه
الازمات خاصه نحن نتحدث عن مباني ضخمه
تهدمت على رؤوس قاطنيها لا تملك فرق
الدفاع المدني سوى بعض العائله الاليات
لرفع الانقاض وجر وجرفها هناك مثلا في
مدينه جنديرس 84 مبنى
هبطت على رؤوسه هل من مساعدات خارجيه او
داخليه بدات تصل الى مناطق الشمال السوري
او شمال غرب سوريا يعني حتى هذه اللحظه
هناك طائرتان عراقيتان هبطت في مطار دمشق
الدولي تحميلان حوالي 70 طن من المواد
الاغاثيه والطبيه
والبطانيات ايضا طائره ايرانيه تحمل
مساعدات لوجيستيه غير ذلك لا توجد اي
مساعدات هذه المساعدات ستصل الى مناطق
سيطره النظام خاصه في اللاذقيه وطرطوس
والجزء الواقع تحت سيطرته في مدينه حلب
بينما حتى الان لم تدخل اي مساعدات
انسانيه الى شمال غرب حلب حيث مناطق نفوز
المعارضه لا من مناطق سيطره النظام ولا
حتى من معبر باب الهوى مع مع تركيا لذلك
الوضع الانساني في هذه البقعه الجغرافيه
وضع ماساوي